now we're going to go into a little bit
more details on the and the theorem that
20 functions exist if only if Kate is
mildly hot on average
so recall that our goal was that because
of the house theorem it suffices to
construct a weak body function
and that's what we're going to do now
okay so here is the construction of the
body function
so first of all of all I'm going to
start off by assuming that we have some
constant C such as the Commodore
complexity of any string X is at most
the length of X plus C this is what's
referred to as the environmental and not
in variance theorem whatever what is it
called a true reality about complexity
which requires the right definition
anyone
anyone true so
um we're gonna let's see be this
constant this constant depends on the
universal turmer much that we have
okay so let us turn now to uh the
definition of money function
so this function is going to take a bit
string as input
and what it's going to do
is it's going to interpret the first
part of that as a program
Pi Prime
and the second part is going to be an
index
so the second part is the roughly of
length log n and this is roughly of
length n
okay now you see that I'm cheating
because the length is supposed to be n
so you need to make the input fit to
this thing this is very annoying to deal
with and I'm not going to tell you about
that but it can be done by using
annoying padding arguments okay uh
[Music]
and this length actually is not going to
be exactly low gun but it's going to be
n plus C and this is going to be a
length n plus c but forget about this
constant C now okay so think of N and
then index I
the next thing we'll do is actually we
take this program and we're not going to
consider the whole thing as a program
but we're going to chop it off
and we're going to chop it off after the
first I bits where I was that index
so you take your thing
look at the index let's say that's 54
then it chop up the the first string
after 54 bits and interpret that as a
program
and that's my program pi
and now we're basically done now what
I'm going to do is just run this program
pi
for T of n steps where this is supposed
to be a little T
okay run it for T of n steps
and output
the output of the program and also the
index
you keep the index and you output this
does the construction make sense
so you really just take your input you
interpret the first string as a program
you're going to chop it up after uh
based on the index you read from the
second part and then you run it and you
output whatever you got together with
the index
now the intuition
for actually let's do intention for y
this should be one way
assuming your hardness of co-worker
complexity
is that if I give you a string and your
goal is to find the common complexity of
this string
if you have someone who can invert this
thing with very good probability let's
say for now you can have someone who can
invert this it probably to one
if you can invert it with probability
one it's very easy
what you do that is you put in your
string that you're getting here you're
getting a string that you're supposed to
find equivalent complex term you put it
in there and then just try
one comma y two comma y three comma Y
and let this guy try to invert it if
this always inverts it
what it's going to do is to say like
let's say that you put in 18 comma y
here
to invert it it needs to find some
pretty much Pi Prime like this that if
you cut it up at
effective I forget what I said 54. left
54 bits
if you run that for polynomial time it
will output the string y
so if this actually finds a pre-image
you know that there exists a small
program that outputs a string
the existed program of length 54. so if
you want to find the smallest program
just start at one two three perfect and
output the first thing it outputs
make sense
so
so if this thing is worse gets easy to
invert then we can actually uh break uh
KT or salt KT
now this might actually not be so
surprising because we can do similar
things actually for uh for sat too
so there are similar construction for
sat
the surprising thing of this
construction is it actually works on
average
awesome
okay so now we're going to reason about
why it works on average
so there is something in the structure
this problem that makes it you know
different from such and construction
from sat
okay so silver contradiction that this
is not a weak money function
that means that we have some attacker
that's going to be inverting it
in fact since it's not a weak Quality
Function it means that for every inverse
polynomial Delta I can find some
attacker that will invert it with one
minus one one minus Delta
okay so I can make it as close to one as
I want
polar mini Clause inverse polynomial
clause
okay
and now what we're going to do is to use
this attacker
to break to to find a heuristic
for KT
in fact what we'll see actually is that
this heuristic will actually solve the
constructive version it's going to find
the witness also in the same way as we
did here right when we voted we actually
find the candidates
okay so here's what the construction
heuristic does the heuristic actually is
going to do exactly the same thing as I
said before that worked in the worst
case
so giving your string y just try all
possible I's
try to invert it if inversion works
great keep that index and output the
smallest one that works
I would like to make one key observation
about this this algorithm here that
we're going to use later on
let's say you have some string y you're
trying to find the chromogo complexity
string okay
if this heuristic actually works when
you feed him the true color complexity
okay if the conversion place was 54 and
you give him 54 comma Y and he inverts
it and he successfully finds a pretty
much
in that case sorry if a does that in
that case I claim the heuristic will
output the right answer
somebody tell me why
let me repeat again if a actually when I
feed them the true combo complexity here
as an I actually managed to invert in
that case I claim the charistically work
on that input
because it definitely won't be able to
invert on any smaller color of
complexity and it's outputting the
minimum so if it exactly so on the
smaller ones there is no problem so you
cannot invert it so I know you're done
what is doing there on the bigger ones I
don't give them either because they're
going to be bigger so it's not going out
with that
okay that's the key on the observation
we're going to rely on
let's go back to the foreign intuitively
you would think that if things work with
high probability
the same type of argument that in the
worst case should work also because
maybe we can just do a you know if you
work with very high probability Over All
Eyes let's just do a union bound because
this probability can make it super super
small it's just a unibond with polymer
things and we're done
because you think oh it's actually
trivial fortunately that argument also
works for sat so there's something wrong
with this argument
and that's actually where things become
interesting
the key Point here is that we are
feeding the heuristic is actually
feeding a
the right distribution of I because it's
uh you know it's I go over all things so
that's like a random thing so that's
fine but why I'm feeding it is not
coming from the right distribution
okay because here in heuristic
the heuristic is getting a uniform
string y then it's supposed to find the
common complexity of
but then in one way function experiment
the attacker is inverting it he's not
devoting it on a random string
he is actually inverting
the output of the one we function and
the one we function what is it doing
it's taking a random program of a
particular length and giving it the
output of a random program
foreign
so
there is no reason to believe that a
random program is going to Output the
random string
in fact it does not if you write the
program into
python it's not going to Output around
the string most of the time it's going
to Output this right
they are very very different
at this point as a cryptographer like uh
this distribution of the far apart we
cannot use this right in crypto we're
used to saying like no if it works well
here I can make it work on a
computational distinguishable
statistical cost distribution but these
are not statisticals they're very
statistic before
everyone's with me
[Laughter]
okay however we'll show that using
accounting argument is this guy should
be made to work anyways okay and the
counting arguments is actually
surprisingly easy so I'm going to give
it to you in two minutes or
it will take two minutes okay I hope
I'll make one
one simplifying assumption just an
annoyance let's assume that this
attacker that is solving the breaking
money function is deterministic if it's
not deterministic it's more annoying but
it can be done also Let's ignore that so
let's assume we have an attacker is
deterministic
okay
and uh I would like to bound
the probability that the heuristic fails
so that's the same thing as looking at
now since deterministic attack is
deterministic look at the the fraction
of y's on which it fails
okay why does it suffice look at the
fraction wise well because each y here
is as common they all appear with
probability 2 to minus n because I'm
picking things at random here
okay so if I want to bound the
probability this fails let me just bound
the number of y's in which it fades
because each of them have to probably
two to the minus n
okay
so let's consider some y on which this
heuristic fails so and we'll try to show
that it won't be too many of them
okay
if y fails if the heuristic fails and
why
what did we learn from this key
observation
the disk has failed in that case the
attacker a
must fail on the input
w
concatenated y where W is the true color
complexity
right because remember if I think if it
works on a true converter complexity
then a is going to Output a True Value
because they don't care about what
happens with small ones because stance
is always no and then because you don't
care because it's bigger
so if it actually works on w and y
then I know that the heuristic worker
also
now let's look at the probability of
which I'm sampling w and y and I'm
feeding it to attacker in this
experiment and one of the function
experiments
so uh
the one-way function
remember it picked the index that's at
random
okay so the index is going to be W with
probability one over n plus C because we
had n plus C allocated for the log M
plus C bits allocated for that okay so
with probability one over M plus c
I'm picking W I'm picking the right
complexity okay
then since I'm doing this truncation I
just need to make sure
that
given the string y it has come over
completion W so there exists some short
program of length W that outputs is
Trick
okay so now I just need to make sure
that the first W bits are exactly that
program
and that opposite probability two to
minus w
right the length of w
okay and since
by we know that the length uh W is at
most n plus C I know that this is
therefore at least one of n plus two
three minus one
so what's the conclusion that the string
here that sample the probability to
terms n if you fail on that then you
must fail here with probability one over
two to minus n
so in conclusion if you fail here with
probability uh
Epsilon you're going to fail here with
Epsilon over n
since I know that I fail here with tiny
tiny probability
listening needs to be tiny times n
and we're done
we're tiny was Delta right
so therefore here I can fail what most
Delta times n and since I can make Delta
as small as I want I can make this a
smallest amount
that's the whole proof
any questions
[Music]
yeah probably
because yeah well I guess it's related
to the fact that this actually shows the
the hardness of the decision version
also where you just need to decide
whether it's a great like uh n minus
logo or not thanks
if that's true would you get a better
Heart Like A instead of losing a factor
program who's literacy log n
in terms of the mildness like or is that
not the only way where it's coming yeah
that's why we talked about that later
yeah yeah
it's a good point I should look at this
but if it's true that would improve the
problem
again this is not for the this is a very
tiny they lost the main loss is going
from weak to strong so I guess we
haven't really attracted
this is saving a login firm when you're
losing a
quadratic term but yeah so with
relationship what you just said is this
the reason that we have to go from week
to strong like we only get a weak one
here is it just coming from this
dividing by oh then thing that you have
to do this argument over all the values
I like I'm trying to ask like where the
no no no no no to do this argument I
need to make sure that it's like I
succeeding very small probability here I
do not fail with small Mobility
like that any like even a factor two
loss would be damaged
and you cannot get away from even a
concept from Seven sector
right so but great question I think it's
a very interesting
okay so we concluded the first part
which is saying that if Kate is mildly
hard Mavericks and we have only
functions now let's move on to the
second part which is the one that
intuitively should be easier but it
turns out to be harder
so we would like to now show that
Katie's mind behold an average if one of
your functions exist
and the high and level idea
is exactly the same one as we've heard
about multiple times already during this
Workshop
uh following raspberry Rhodes
we start off with a 1A function
and we're going to construct the prg
s should be killed by um mktp Oracle so
therefore we know 20 functions can't
exist
that's the intuition right
so we construct a pog
remember Pig in my context it's a
cryptographic PhD this is an object that
takes a small seed outputs a long string
and this string should be
computationally indistinguishable
from a tool Runner string by all
polynomial time distinguishers so it's a
string that you cannot tell apart if the
the
output.pg or truly random for all
polynomial time algorithms
okay and results by here show that for
one function you can get such a prg
that's great
and as I said this mktp Oracle in two
tool should be able to distinguish these
two things
because student strings have small combo
complexity random strings have large
Colonial complexity by standard counting
arguments so therefore you can tell them
apart so let's go over it uh in a little
bit more detail this argument even
though we've seen it before for
everybody who wasn't here before
so
uniform random strings by a classic
counting arguments that you've seen
before have
if I take a n bit two and bit string
it's going to have
complexity and also time boundary
complexity roughly 2N so with high
probability uh two and minus slogan
whereas if I look at the output of a prg
at 6 n Bits And expands it to two and
bits that's going to have Canoga
complexity roughly or it will always
have Commodore complex and plus order
one because to describe the output here
you just need the seed
so this
prgs are very funny objects it outputs
something that looks random but in terms
of converging complexity it's very not
random
that's very small Commodore complexity
so let's say we have an algorithm H that
can break uh that computes KT and let's
see why it breaks the pag well very easy
clearly if you can tell a podcast a
small ktrl logic KT if the KT is small
then you know that you're here for sure
and when a kit is large then you know
that you're here with high probability
great
okay that's the old argument
I claim that this works very well when
you can compute KT with probability one
but if you have an oracle that only
computes KT with high probability
you're in trouble
and let's see why
I get something uniform
the thing works with high probability
good here it's gonna output the right
answer
okay
when I give it something pseudorandom
unfortunately I have no clue what it's
going to do
why is that I have an oracle that works
let's say with 99 probability of random
strings
how many pseudonym strings do I have
basically none right they're very very
sparse
so it could fail on all of them
and it would still be an awesome KT
solver
foreign
Valentine's talk actually
it does actually if you have a heuristic
that is errorless or one-sided error you
can make this argument go through but
what we're looking for is something that
is it can make errors in both ways and
then it's a problem
okay so the issue here is that these
things have tiny probability mass and
that's why we can't use this argument
but
what we realized is actually if you
start off with a stronger PhD
some more sophisticated objects not just
any PhD
but a nicer type of pog
something referred to as an entry
preserving PhD or actually that's what
we wanted to use but we can't so we need
to use some more complicated objects
something we're going to conditionally
anti-presering PG which sounds like a
mouthful I will try to convince it's not
as horrible as it sounds but if you use
such a thing intuitively this is a prg
that makes sure that output actually has
enough entropy in it and if there is
enough entropy in it even though in
statistical distance it's far
because it has to be because it's output
of a PNG you can still use a similar
type of counting argument as before to
argue that it's going to succeed still
so if the channel entropy of the prg is
sufficiently high you can still make the
heuristic work on it
so that's the idea
okay so let me kind of introduce this
notion
so 90 PG is just like a normal PhD
but there's additional and preserving
property which just requires that the
output of the pag has high Shannon
entropy
and it's kind of
ideally would like to say has high mean
entropy we don't have to achieve that so
until our Channel entropy is good enough
and one can show using a similar style
counting argument a little bit more
sophisticated but if you have an
antiperserving PhD that actually implies
that Kate is mildly hot on average
so KT heuristics do actually eat up and
break this cover and through preserving
phds
foreign
preserving ones make sure that there is
like a prg actually in principle can
have very very little uh entropy much
less than uh
and uh than what you want so you could
have like very very very very Sports
outputs okay and here I need to have
something that actually has enough kind
of uh it's not two sparse you know to
get the heuristic to actually work but
uh isn't any much more than 2N
we'll get to it here so here what we're
going to look at is something that goes
n Bits to n plus C Logan bits
you can actually I won't discuss it here
but to prove this more sophisticated
results you actually need to have the
ones that are longer but for the first
result it's going to be enough to
consider PJ goes from M bits to M plus C
Logan bits
okay so now the probability mass is
pretty big within this
is high and that's the intuition
uh so can we get this type of anti
Brazilian pgs so the first happy news is
that actually this most standard
construction of a prg from one
permutations actually then to preserving
so if you haven't seen these things this
is going to be very fast now but let me
anyway just kind of Flash the
construction
so this is the the Gola Cleveland uh
um
construction.pg you start off with a
one-way permutation f
you apply the permutation to to your
seed
and then you also output an additional
bit
that is obtained as taken the inner
product between some random string R and
the the pretty much
and this is referred to the golak 11
predicate
so this type of in the product
Construction
how's the property at this final bit is
an instinctively random
and the first part here
is not only indistinguishable from
random It Is Random
so therefore this thing actually has
even mean entropy this is a great
Construction
so very nice the only problem is this
starts with a wonderful rotation
and we don't know how to get the one
with permutation from audience of KT
that would be awesome but we don't
uh to get a one-way function we need to
use a much more complicated construction
that's what Hilda did they constructed a
PhD for many functions but that requires
a lot more work and unfortunately we
don't know if it's anti-preserving it
doesn't look like it
or at least it's hard to prove that it
is
and it's still an open problem how to
get the entropy preserving PG for money
functions
no I actually uh
so I talked to ifta heitner who has
these improvements of the of this and
quite interestingly he said that this
notion of something very similar notion
of Enterprise PSG they never published
anything about but it was the kind of
they were thinking about that as a
stepping stone to get more efficient
constructions and they were trying also
for a very long time getting that thing
and got stuck and I don't remember if he
had any barriers to it but there seems
to be something that people have kind of
in order to get more efficient precise
on PhD they kind of also naturally this
is an objective natural card kind of
so it seems hard yeah it would be nice
to actually if I can formally prove
that's impossible like we don't need it
here but it's still it will make
everything much more nicer and simpler
if one could just get it it's a very
natural concept
um all right so what we did kind of like
if you can't solve the hot problem just
go around it right
and and it turned out that actually you
don't need this full power
because this mktp oracles actually
can break more funny objects also okay
so actually I don't need a full plg
to be eaten by a
mktp it actually turns out to have this
conditional prg so what's a conditional
PhD it's a PhD such that there exists
some event this event is not computable
well actually it will be computable but
it's not efficiently computable but it
doesn't have to be computable just some
event e
such that if I condition on this event e
the output with PhD is in distinguish
from random
and if a condition on event e then it
has a lot of entropy
and
turns out that if I have such a
condition and deliver the PG
then
you can already show
hardness of
City
you need anything about the probability
of the event or no but the event
actually will not be too small because
of this ntp condition
pop-up
okay and and then the second thing we
can show now is actually uh using one of
the functions you can get it
okay this is going to be super super
fast okay so if you haven't seen these
constructions of pgs actually what we're
going to do is we're going to kind of
take like one of the early stages of of
a hill
it's kind of like a warm-up case of Hill
uh and and even earlier constructions of
the constructed
phds from this object called a regular
one-way function it's a regular 1A
function is a function where each output
doesn't have maybe one pretty much that
would be a permutation or injectable
function but has a a fixed number of
images so yeah each output has let's say
two three r pre-images
and R is a regularity
from regular warning function it's
actually much easier to get a PhD and
the classical construction of plg then
you try to do something like collar 11.
okay if I go back to the construction
if you apply it to something here you
output your bit
but the problem now is that uh
because of regularity
you uh
you're losing like this thing might not
be be random anymore
because it's like very compressing
okay
so what I should do then is just try to
like extract out some extra bits from
the input
so the construction
is
take your function
okay
the outputer function
has some entropylets okay it actually
has n minus r entropy R is the
regularity so I can apply and extracted
to output and get something random
from the output
but that's not enough I only got n minus
r bits but then the input still has some
enthropy in fact orbits of entropy
because it's all regular so can I want
to apply an extractor also to the input
okay so this is kind of a method for
going from this regular function to
something that's basically almost like
one to one ish
right because I'm applying the function
and apply the extractor on the output
and I know how many bits of entropy uh
how much Min entropy the output has
because it's regular it's extract out
exactly what I need and then I'm losing
some entropy from the input so let me
apply the extract lots of input to
squeeze out extra intimidation there
and then finally I take the Gunner 11
bits
so that works if I know the regularity
we don't know the regularity here
so I'm just going to guess the
regularity
okay I'm going to let I be a guest
regularity I mean that's going to be
another input to the function
now this sucks as a prg because if this
I is not correct
well it's not the regular function so
you know it just doesn't work
but the key observation here is that
every function
you can actually think of a function as
being made up of many regular functions
right
if by restricting the domain to like you
know let's look at regularity one okay
let's look at all the inputs that have
regularity one or we call it the
generous you want let's look at all the
inputs of generacy too blah blah so you
can think of a function as being made up
of a bunch of small
regular things I just don't know which
one it is if I could figure out it made
a given out but if I knew which one it
was awesome then I could pick that I
don't know okay I'm just going to pick
it at random
okay and now if I condition an event I
made a good guess we're good to go
so this is not a prg
at all it's it doesn't work as but it's
a conditional PhD
okay this is super high level but
hopefully I conveyed the intuition that
something can be done
um
okay and that concludes the uh the
second theorem
and uh
as I mentioned then as we discussed
already you can also State this as a
decisional problem you don't need to
view it as this computational problem
but it's also deciding whether the the
Commodore complex is more or less than n
minus Logan
and
um
and that's it okay so let's now go back
to this in pregnancy World thing and
like really discuss why this
characterization gets some implications
for in paglaces once okay and the first
one we would like to go back to is to
revisit this question of whether we can
base 1A functions on MP naught equal to
p
okay
so we've now shown this equivalent
between these two things mktp being hot
on average uh and uh
you know if we could just go from MP
being hard to mktp being hard that is
proving worse like MP completely so I
get to p
okay and then also get a worst case
average case reduction compared to here
great we're done that's all we need to
do
okay so uh and the Curious Thing is that
actually hero Harris awesome work from
2018 does show a worst case average case
reduction going from here to here
so now you're like well this is all I
need to do proven completeness
not so fast okay unfortunately irahara
only showed the worst case average case
reduction if you define average case
hardness using errorless the errorless
notion average is hardness
and what we need here is hard on average
with inspect a two-sided error
okay so there is actually kind of a a
gap and I personally think that these
Notions have ever less hardness and two
set of hardness are actually very very
different creatures like the errorless
notion seems to really be
like heuristic I would expect there are
two types of heuristic out there really
right there's weak heuristic and strong
heuristica one is where uh where you
have errorless
basically errorless hardness really
should be equivalent to worst case
hardness two set of hardness I don't
know yet okay if it's equivalent or not
but clearly
foreign
hardness from worst case hardness
even for MP
uh
now I do want to point out times okay so
if you go if you can result lead to a
step then you have uh the Holy Grail but
it's also the case now that you need to
resolve both these steps
okay so it's just instructive to just
see why you need to do it if you can
base one of functions on the hardness of
MP
okay then I claim that you need to prove
that mptp is MP complete it is a
non-blackbox techniques Maybe
if anyone can do that argument for me
let's say you can prove that you can
base if you can base one of functions on
holiday Slam please so you have a 1A
function Oracle and you know how to use
that to solve MP now I would like you to
show that
using mktp Oracle you can solve NP
why is that
breaks away yeah then we don't get the P
breaks the one a function and when a
function breaks this done okay and in
the same way you can show you need to go
from here to here
so both those two things need to be done
right if you want to sell the Holy Grail
you need to prove mktps is MP complete
and you need to go from where's your
server case
so let me again like emphasize this is
not coincidental it's not that this
technique is kind of meta complexity
here is
you know unapproved sources it's a
necessary approach but you need to do
this
that's why it's an empty complete in the
sense of like non-blackbox empty
complete right
so there's so many different known
definitions that have to complete but
really let's let's go of this like
touring reduction thing it's like I'm
definitely complete this with non-back
post reductions that's the right line
okay now
can we can we do better or can we do
something different we would like to
maybe you know can we sidestep this this
question of proving happy completeness
no we can't because as I mentioned it's
necessary but maybe we can kind of you
know again try to walk around it and
implicitly show it somehow
so in this uh
later work what we showed us if we
instead consider the conditional
converter complexity problem
then the first step here can be done
actually
you can prove MP completeness of the
conditional communal complexity problem
okay and then the only missing step
and addition you can prove the same
equivalent this equivalence actually
works out directly in the same way as
before so there's nothing to really show
here so you just need to show this is
empty complete and then afterwards that
means there's only this step that's
remaining
okay so really the only thing that
remains is to get the worst used average
case reduction for the conditional
convertible complexity problem
so recall conditional complexity is the
same as
KT but now I'm given an X and a z and
the goal is to compute the equivalent of
x if you get Z as an input
okay now there is a little caveat the
original definition of conditional
complexity was with respect to Turing
machines for our result here we need a
ram modular computation time Personnel
border by this this is anyway the the
right model ramps are better than tour
machines but uh
okay it is what it is it's still open to
show and complete this returning
machines
okay so the first
case or first crawler of this thing is
what I just mentioned if you want to
base one of your functions on NP notice
at BPP that's equivalent
to getting a worst case average case
reduction for mcktp that's exactly what
you need to do
okay so again this is a new another
complexity theoretic Meta Meta
complexity interpretation of uh this
Holy Grail
and a second interpretation
is the following
if you just want to
roll out
heuristica which one is it heuristica
yes
no pestilence sorry pestilence too many
names here
if you just want to write pestilence
what this means is if you just want to
get get a construction of when it
functions from average case hard to MP
okay let's not go all the way to the the
Holy Grail I just want to show if amp is
hot on average
can I get a money function
that's equivalent to showing that the
uniform distribution is the hardest
distribution for mctdp on average
so again let's see why that is the case
okay let's show that let's say that you
can show this that if mckdp is hot for
some sample distribution
then it's hard for the uniform
okay
in that case let's assume that MP is
average case hard that means that there
exists some problem in NP and some
distribution for which it's hard to
decide this language
since mktp is MP complete you can now
translate this origin problem and
original distribution into some new
distribution over mktp mcktp
right
such as mcktp is now hard over that
sample distribution
if you can go from uniform to from any
distribution to uniform then you can go
to uniform
and then we have that from uniform it's
equivalent to any functions
because this was One Direction and the
other direction you can do
the same as before
okay so
really we now have that
getting
rolling out
passy land is equivalent showing uh that
the uniform distribution is is hard the
hardest distribution for mctp
yeah do you have any natural problem
where you can actually show you some
distributions
I'm not sure
yeah I think like discreet love for
instance like anything that has run some
disability maybe but at least
yeah yes so beautiful but that is like
it takes a natural probably makes it
unnatural right so using hashing you can
do these things but look the world is
what it is I cannot change
so this is what you need to do what do
you mean part of this distribution hello
like the hardest distribution if it's
hard for some distribution it's hard for
uniform
if
[Applause]
yeah I don't care about you yeah the
hardest meaning is not exactly yeah yeah
it's hard listen now it's not the
podcast
it's how this in a sense is like
like yeah yeah the uniform is complete
yeah
um so let me mention like
three three minutes about how the
problems have to complete this the
techniques here are really just boring
stuff from uh rahuli lango's work but uh
so I'm gonna do it very very fast just
to highlight like an interesting open
problem here that's uh
so the way you you can prove and
complete this on the conditional
communical complexity problem is going
to be a exactly following rahul's work
to reducing it from the bounded set
cover problem so here you're giving uh
some sets uh and
um
so we set several Universe uh one Trend
and the goal is to find a small set
cover
okay and we know that this is a empty
hot approximate result by travisal
and uh
what we want to do now is take this set
cover instance and turn it into a comogo
complexity instance such that if the set
cover is Big then the complex is big if
the set cover is small then the
complexity is small the conditional
commercial complexity okay so uh so
following what uh
Rahul did we're going to first replace
each element in the universe by a
by a random string a random string which
therefore is going to have logical
complexity
and now you can think of a set here
as
being described by a string that
contains the the
elements from the universe so if this is
the universe each string has now is
replaced by random string now this set
S1 which is one three is going to
contain this string and this string
and 2 3 contains this one and this one
okay
that's uh that's step one
and uh now intuitively
what we're going to do is
we're going to ask
this is going to be the string we'd like
to find the commercial texture the whole
universe you'd like to recover all these
end strings
or n times M strings
each string is of length M under n
strings
okay so it's a string of length n times
n
what Rahul did was he considered his
Oracle problem and he gave
uh you put all these sets inside
different Oracles
and the idea now is that if you know a
set cover
then you can just point to
some of these sets
and that's a way to summarize
this string in a very sixteenth way
so if you have a small set cover I'm not
pointing to this this and this could now
we're just having the indexes of the of
the sets you can compress the string
since we don't have access to oracles we
need to somehow put these sets into the
auxiliary input
okay and uh what we'll do is just take
these sets and put it into random
position in AUX input
and I'm going to now use the fact that
the auxiliary input is much much longer
than the running time of the uh
comogo complexity the T in the combo
complexity
so if you
don't know
where to look
you can kind of not figure out where
these things are in the string so really
think of this as kind of an information
theoretic way of obfuscating these
oracles that the hole is using I'm just
placing it in the random position it's
very long string
so you can if you have long time you can
just enumerate it and just find where
they are
okay
but if you don't have that time
then you can only do it if you know like
you can specify what are if you have a
set cover
that's where you need to run
exactly
so that's really the RAM and uh so the
reason I wanted to mention uh this so
basically disease so long that if you're
time bomb that thing you cannot figure
out where they are because you're just
going to look at random positions it
doesn't really help you okay
and
um
okay so the reason I wanted to to
mention this even though this is really
very high level it's really mostly based
on our own work here is that
there's a very upsetting reason to have
this uh long Z
because there's a more recent work by
hirohara that shows that if you can make
this Z small you can use symmetry
information theorems
remember from earlier talk to symmetry
information is a way to relate
conditional commercial complexity to
unconditional right
so if you can actually do this
the relation condition to unconditional
then you have also shown mpga hardness
ramp completeness of the unconditionally
one the normal one
okay unfortunately this kilometer
information style thing will only work
where Z is short
so if you can do this kind of
obfuscation here in a more succinct way
where the string is not very long then
you've actually shown a completeness of
uh mktp
so I think that's a very
very clear open question and it's like
maybe doable and that would be a very
clean way of getting uh uh towards
getting um MP completeness of mqtp
so um so some airport we've seen so far
was that uh
the first result was mktp is complete
for only functions
uh
is manufacturing completes that means
that if you want to go from here to here
you need to show that mktps and be
complete and it works with average
construction for this and now using the
conditional version we got the following
two things that if you want to get this
result you just need a worse established
case reduction because it is simply
complete already and additionally that
the uniform is complete for uh in
average case sales
okay so those are interpretation we
still have this thing left here of like
how do we go from from here to here
okay and the way that's going to be done
is by showing actually uh that uh you
can get characters when it functions
from MK little TP
so let's recall what this mktp was with
little T so this is this Levin notation
called Moga complexity
and
the level notes of convocal complexity
is of a string X is a length or the cost
of the cheapest programmed output string
where you define cost as adding up
length plus logarithm of the running
time
as I'm looking at the the cheapest
program that output is string X where
the cost of a program is the the length
of it plus the logarithm of the running
time
now we've already or not here but in
earlier talks what we heard about was
that this problem actually is very
different from nktp which is above
because it's actually
it's not an NP it's X complete
with respects to non-uniform reductions
okay so what that means is what was
shown before was that if X is not inside
P slash poly in that case MKT little TP
is not in P slash poly
so what we observed was actually
uh you can show something stronger you
can show that if X is not equal to BPP
then this problem is also hard for BPP
and not just hot for BPP it's actually
average case hard
and this is just by using exactly the
framework that Valentin was talking
about in the CLK paper
so you can actually get from
this assumption that XP is noticed at
BPP
so our less hardness for uh for PPP
and the next thing we can show and this
was done independently by us and also by
uh handling Rahul that uh I have two
study or holders of mktp actually is
equivalent to any functions
okay in One Direction This previous uh
the PHD proof that with it works
directly
uh in the other direction you need to
tweak the proof a little bit I'll maybe
mention two words about about it
so in fact in the remaining a few
minutes let me very high level kind of
again sketch this this argument that
you've seen many times but I think it's
really nice to drive home again this is
really that's just a cakk uh uh style uh
argument because it kind of explains why
normal Pages actually can be broken by a
RLS algorithm
uh okay this is
okay but the conclusion then is like if
you want to base one of the functions in
X multiple DVP that's equivalent to
showing actually something weaker than
what I mentioned in a slide the only
thing you need to do is to show
reduction from errorless to two-sided
error hardness
okay
so this really is very these Notions are
really super super different errorless
harder and two set of hardest are crazy
different because if you can do that you
haven't just shown the Holy Grail you've
shown like the super hole again you
shouldn't have to get like
crypto from X not in PvP and x dot BP is
true okay that one
[Laughter]
mpm versus P I don't know about that
that empty like that's yeah
bonus that's a uniform
s yes uniform distribution beautiful
yeah
yes uniform yeah
so let's uh go over cakk uh style
argument again here we show is that if
you have a an inefficient uh PhD and
this is something you can get from the
assumption that the X is not inside BPP
using the impegulation videos on
construction so in periods and videos
show that if you have not in PvP then
you can get an inefficient prg
uh now I'd like to use such an
inefficient PG to show that mptp is is
uh is not is errorless hard
and
same argument as as before we want to
distinguish between uniform and uh and
so the random we have a little bit more
uh now we're looking at mktp and mktp
actually is good because it can also
kill inefficient phds
as long as they're just running
sub-exponential time because I'm
charging logarithmically for running
time and that's kind of what's what's so
cool about the mkt11 complexity as long
as it's you know sub exponential running
time it's fine because you're only going
to add this little list there
okay the problem here as we already
discussed with prgs is that heuristic
doesn't always work right if it worked
always would be done that's the previous
uh or proof
but it might fail okay and uh
in the uniform we know it works very
high probability and we know it's going
to Output zero with high probability
because it's uniform it's a right
distribution that's what it's supposed
to work on but when I give him outputs
to the pag I don't know what it's going
to do
okay it might fail on all of them
but if this is an errorless heuristic
we know that it's either going to give
the right answer or a bot it's right
that's what the errorless I think does
it never gives the wrong answer it just
says I give up
and the key Point here is that if this
guy
right
if this guy gives up
then you know you can always say that
it's uh so the random
right because then you know for sure
you're going to succeed when it's suit
random you always get the right answer
when it's uniform you're still only
gonna lose its full probability
so this whole approach still works when
you have a
errorless hardness and that's uh
okay The Next Step where they really
don't have much time for uh
was if you looked at the original PPG
construction needed to run the program
for to Val steps and with that the T of
n came from the running time bundle
money function when you deal with
mktp we don't have our own time bound we
don't know the running time so how long
should we run this function
that's a problem right
and uh so let's say we run it for some
tfl steps for now
and let's modify it so I'm going to
Output note the indexes I but I plus log
of the actual running time
okay
what you can show now is that actually
going to work
it will work as long as the running time
is uh is actually at most this
okay but the problem is
when it's long or not what do we do it's
an issue
okay so sometimes it could be since I'm
doing with this mktp it could be that
the shortest programs running time is
exponential right with mktp that could
happen
so refer that as the KT Witness
is that the shortest program actually
the witness is the the cologne
complexity
it turns out they can show using a very
uh simple uh
Lemma versus very simple
statement is actually most strings don't
have doesn't happen most things most
strings have a KT witness with small
running time
and if I know that most things have a
small runtime I can just cut it off at
that time and then we're done okay so
I'm running out of time so I'm not going
to tell you about that but it's the
proof is this it's the one-liner
well three on slide but one in the paper
so um
all right so summing up now we kind of
see in this whole picture tally is going
to tell us uh more about this thing and
let me just you know what's outside here
[Laughter]
let me now unfortunately running out of
time but I wanted to mention a little
bit more about this uniform being the
hardest here okay so as we said if you
wanted to rule out pestiland
you wanna
it suffices here to show that for mctp
uh you can go from any distribution to
to uniform so the question is can you
make any of these things work for any
distribution and there is this very nice
uh recent
results by uh
illango run and santanam that actually
shows
a different characterization when it
functions using the hardness of cake
complexity
so lots of time but the unbanned one
with respect any distribution
so this show so they stated this as a as
a gap problem they said distinguish
between being large and small Commodore
complexity for certain uh polamal and
computable um uh bounds that are
sufficiently far apart if there exists
some distribution for which this is hard
that's equivalent to the existence of
only functions
so with the journey we had kind of
rephrasing of of this thing you can say
that's when the functions exists efflon
if just approximating KT
is uh is hard with respect and
efficiently sample distribution this
really is a rephrasing of
of what they did
so this is very nice because now it's
reflecting any distribution right if if
only functions exists then KT is hard
for for some sampling distribution and
if k sorry not K T but K and if K is
hard for some efficient assumptible
distribution then uh then one of your
functions exists and the proof is
actually very easy it's it's here and in
my remaining one minute I'm gonna give
you it because it's a it's very
structural
the first direction is you want to go
from you want to show that the funny
functions exist then K is hot for some
distribution and remember we had to work
very hard for that before okay but now I
just need to find some distribution to
do it not the uniform one and then it's
trivial because from when I function you
go to PNG and the pag defines a
distribution on which uh the
distinguisher like this cha Oracle
actually works because I can with 50 I'm
going to be uniform 50
the PHD so
that's actually if you succeed with
hyperbilt on that distribution then you
can tell that's exactly what means to
teleport so if I can pick the
distribution very easy to prove that
step and the Second Step which is the
interesting one
you want to show that if uh K is hard
for some samplable distribution then you
get a 1A function
and that's going to rely on results so
Levin and Luby both actually
uh that that showed that if only
functions don't exist then we can do
approximate counting and in fact we can
do uh we can estimate the density uh of
uh the probability that something was
sampled with so if I sample some string
X from some efficiently sample
distribution if one a functions don't
exist
you can find out what was the
probability of this string being sampled
yeah that's what IL uh Square say
and now let's use this
this uh probability estimator to compute
Commodore complexity
and this actually now will follow
directly actually from a coding theorem
actually that uh that was already
mentioned
that said that look if I know the
probability of sample that's actually
going to be a mobile complexity
okay so what you should just do is just
take the probability oh sorry the
logarithm of the probability is your
Commodore complexity
and uh the key yeah the argument is here
but it's uh it's a One Direction is the
coding theorem which is particularly is
in this setting in that direction is
coming so just doing this thing and
Computing the the logarithmet of the
density that's actually going to give
you an estimate within login because you
lose a little bit here uh because you
don't have this prefix free uh
definition so you lose login or some
logins but that gives you the complexity
all right so this is it's very nice
because now it it really it works for
any samplable distribution
yeah minus login is good enough for me
I don't care about prefix really okay so
it's really cool it works for any what's
less cool is that it works for any okay
let's let me explain this because this
is uh
uh a kind of the fact that it works for
any seems like a great thing but
actually when you look at what happens
here the fact that it works with any it
really
what happens here is the distribution is
the one a function
right so this says what IL say really is
that look if you're gonna if this
problem is hard for some distribution
then this distribution must be a value
function
so
in some sense you're saying if money
functions exist Then I then I know a
distribution because I can get using a
PhD I can get some distribution but if
this problem is hot for some
distribution and distribution is the one
a function itself so it doesn't really
give me the insight into how to find
this one a function and that's very
different from before when we we had it
was a concrete problem so here it's not
a single problem
really we know there exists an element
in the class but that element is
actually specified by the one function
okay so that at first looks like
annoying but
but maybe there's still an approach from
this through a lot pestilence
because if I only want to do is to rule
out pestilence
let's say that NP is hard on average
okay there exists some distribution for
which amp is hard
if I can now take that distribution and
turn it in distribution for k
that would be great
because then I have money function
and we know that K is already complete
right so after all this really should be
easy to go for it like okay clearly is
already complete clearly you should be
able to solve empty completes MP
problems right indeed one can get this
cover reductions
unfortunately
um
this approach was kind of like it seemed
very promising now but sometime and suck
showed that actually you cannot have a
non-adaptive reduction
from
mp22k
okay and really if you want to go if if
you want to make this step work that if
MP is on average then then K becomes
harder on average for some distribution
you need this reduction to be a
non-adaptive reduction to to say that
like my distribution here would like to
get this distribution there to do that I
need to have a non-adaptive reduction
and unfortunately
those things are not possible
but maybe one can still somehow overcome
it
okay all right so in that case I'm gonna
sum up and say that my conclusion here
that we've seen is that actually
understanding uh in pagasa's words at
least you know to get 20 functions
necessitates uh economogo complexity
this is an if only if you really need to
understand this uh questions like
complexity there's been a lot of amazing
progress in the last few years and uh
lots of new papers coming out it's very
exciting I also wanted to mention that
this is applications also to
de-randomization we didn't have time to
get into that but uh maybe Yani will
talk about uh that in later on
so you can get comboga complexity
characterizations of uh what it means to
BPP versus P question in particular
that's why I Define this new world
randomalia if you understand randomalia
we also can do that using Google
complexity and let me end with Frank
Zappa
[Applause]
super quick questions I by the way I'll
make up the time in my talk
questions
thank you